pronta la
tanto ve lo portate una tonnellata di
cibo qui
[Musica]
ma mi sa che fame
quest'anno eppure
nascosta e quelle
cinque di emergenza dove più verso
la vita
dai l'ora di mangiare
non mi ricordo dopo la nascosto quel
cioccolato forse sta dietro
[Musica]
forse non lo sono mangiato
mattino ti ricordi dove l'ho messo
a vita dai
briga 10 fuori dal normale
ma non capisco non capisco proprio come
abbia fatto a scomparire questo cibo sei
stato tu merlino hai mangiato tu il mio
cibo
c1 si nasconde il cibo adesso lo devo
riordinare
frontale tra l'auto non ho portato una
tonnellata di cibo qui
è immagino 6 forme pure tua
ma sei stato talmente tanto tempo in
acqua che sei diventata blu
sì
allora voglio
un chilo di pasta
come
che ti è successo lo porto è diventata
russa
si va bene portavi tutto il prima
possibile ci sentiamo dopo ciao
cosa che sta succedendo sta cambiando
colore
questa trasformazione in siria sta
trasformando anche i capelli li mai
tanta fame anche tu vero se
ti capisco ti capisco
e chi sei
chi è non ho mica capito
come ho preso tua vita 3 si è mangiata
certi è stato tu lo sai che è stato
effettivamente le assomiglio un sacco ma
non è che lei mangiata poi lai assorbita
e
se è diventata come lei tipo non capisco
come lei assorbita lai mangiata
non capisco cioè io adesso devo vivere
con te che mangi le sirene in effetti
sempre proprio una murena
[Musica]
mi dispiace per te ma non tenere
[Risate]
presente che proverei per basilea iii
[Musica]
non ci credo che era eliminata ho
mangiata sicuramente l'avrei nascosta da
qualche parte dimmi dove
è troppo tardi però eliminato anch'io
berlino vieni a mangiarti questa murena
vieni merlino aiutami
ho trovato il suo punto debole
ho paura di essere mangiata a berlino
bravo mourinho bravo e adesso dimmi
subito dove anita altrimenti teese
guinzaglio berlino addosso
[Applauso]
in piscina tu come ho fatto a non
pensarci dove poteva essere altro
ovviamente era in piscina non può uscire
dall'acqua ed eviterà la bella che tutta
la ministeri
vabbè lascerò qui merlino a controllarti
berlino bella controllare
per andar lì non vi di guardia questo ti
potrà controllare
berlino non fartela scappare
bravo murray non controlla buongiorno
tale
6 forse vitale mi ha fatto uno scherzo
mi ha portato fa mentre dormivo ma
perché
che cosa sono quelli non hanno un'aria
amichevole
aiuto
[Musica]